j'accueille maintenant ils avaient le
couteau
isabelle coûtant bonsoir ça alors vous
êtes avocat et pas avocate parce que si
on vous dit avec 4 vous répondez
appelez-moi mettra 6 etc si ce n'est les
écrivains a maintenant se font appeler
auteurs chacun fait ce qu'il veut
d'accord moi je considère que c'est la
même chose alors vous publiée à
l'archipel épouse et carlos un amour
sous haute tension où vous racontez
votre histoire d'amour et votre mariage
avec ilitch ramirez sanchez dit carlos
le terroriste vénézuélien convertis à
l'islam alors carlos a été longtemps
désigné par la presse comme le
terroriste le plus recherché de la
planète la sphère de la rue marbeuf
l'attentât de la gare saint-charles à la
présomption d'innocence d'accord contre
le train le capitole pareil pareil de
drugstore saint-germain pareil la
fusillade de la rue toullier prescrits
et rue toullier on en parlera si vous
n'aimez rue toullier c'est pas un
attentat si vous dites que c'est le
mossad
d'accord il ya attentes à la chanson
française quand même avec big bisou il
fallait qu'ils la pâte
il fallait il la femme dans le bel
connaissant d'un missile à deux étages
franchement il ne pense qu'à ça alors ça
serait comme celle là tu l'as fait
maintenant elle apparaît que c'était à
refaire elle est bien cette vanne alors
carlos enlevés au soudan par les
services secrets français et pas par des
officiers de la police judiciaire sur la
base d'un mandat français et pas
internationale donc il ya un ami à vous
qui disent cette phrase assez drôle
carlos est le seul étranger entré
irrégulièrement sur le territoire
national que le gouvernement se refuse à
expulser ça c'est vrai c'est très c'est
très subtil
ouais mais ça aurait été des officiers
de la police judiciaire c'était tout
aussi illégal parce que le mandat
d'arrêté français par internet mais de
toute façon je ne crois pas que la
police française quelle que soit sa
qualification et le droit d'aller
enlever des gens à l'étranger
oui mais des gens qui ont fait des
attentats comme ça change riz et les
adjoints taille sur va prouver
les attentats ont eu lieu mais qui a
organisé qui est l'auteur on n'en sait
rien pensez pas que c'est carlos ou
sûrement pour alors dans le carlos qui
est incarcéré dans gala santé depuis
1994 il a passé huit ans et 63 jours en
isolement total
et vous dites dans votre bouquin que le
maximum ces trois mois la france vient
d'être condamnée par la cour européenne
parce que c'est illégal
donc on est dans l'illégalité du début à
la fin
les avocats font ce qu'ils peuvent y
compris moi hein
mais apparemment la justice française ne
tient pas tellement content des lois
votées
voilà mais c'est pas seulement ça il
faut essayer d'imaginer c'est imaginable
que les uns ou les autres vous soyez
interdit de parler à qui que ce soit
pendant des mois mais moins des mois des
années
essayez de vous mettre dans cette
situation quand on l'a choisi c'est ce
qu'on appelle les anachorètes bon la
rigueur a tellement d'un à correct mais
l'être humain est ce qu'il est un être
social et ça rend fou
bon on l'a pas rendu fou parce qu'il est
indestructible et c'est ce qu'on a
essayé de faire alors pour vous car l'os
n'est pas terroriste en fait un militant
politique et le terme de terrorisme vous
dites c'est un instrument de propagande
pour réduire au silence ceux qui ne sont
pas dans le bon camp on peut dire ça
comme ça
aussi que c'est l'adversaire les
mannequins sont très forts nous sommes
d'ailleurs tous dans l'axé du mal
j'espère que participer à l'axé du mal
non moi je suis dans l'axé du bien sûr
vous sous-entendez en dix ans a
finalement c'est vous comparez carlos
aux résistants pendant la deuxième
guerre mondiale que le gouvernement de
vichy ap les terroristes et qui étaient
en fait des résistants vous dites que
c'est un résistant c'est comme ça que
vous défendez le nord mais pas seulement
c'est un responsable un dirigeant
politique un homme politique vous avez
des hommes politiques exercent le
pouvoir parce que soit ils ont été élus
soit ils ont pris le pouvoir par la
force et en tout cas c'est d autorité
reconnue personnel et conteste mais
l'histoire fait que ça change les des
gens nelson mandela a été en prison 26
ans je crois et puis c'est devenu aéro
admis internationalement donc l'histoire
et est très frivole je dirais en
fonction des intérêts à un moment donné
et il dit je ramène sanchez dit carlos
par la dst est un homme politique est
quelqu'un qui a connu c'est sans doute
la personne qui s'est le plus parmi les
survivants sur ce qui s'est passé dans
les coulisses de la politique interne en
syrie pendant 30 ans et quelques jours
les clés pour savoir ce qui s'y passe
alors vous allez jusqu'à dire que vous
faites pas de différence entre les
civils tués par la bombe qui manque sa
cible ce qu'on appelle les dégâts
collatéraux et les victimes d'un
attentat c'est gonflé quand même ça non
seulement je fais pas de différence mais
je considère qu'il est beaucoup plus
injuste de tuer en bombardant à 5000 m
c'est ce qu'on appelle la tuerie des
lâches
d'ailleurs cinq mille métiers aucun
risque vous avez une famille qui fait un
mariage en afghanistan vous avez des
bombardiers américains 5000 m qui tu
loupes sont sans faire de discrimination
va dire ça c'est le pire ont poussé plus
grave de tuer une famille en bombardant
l'afghanistan qu'en mettant une bombe
rue marbeuf si l'on fait qu'il ait mis
une bombe rue marbeuf satuc beaucoup
moins de monde parce que ses cibles et
on n'entend pas toujours parler et ça
évite de gains
et ça évite que notamment cet exemple
terrible des familles entières soient
dessinés en un mariage dire que pour
vous en faites
et ça n'engage que vous bien évidemment
mais le terrorisme peut influer sur la
politique d'un gouvernement d'une façon
moins un homme d'une femme sans école
voilà moins criminel et grenoble qu'une
guerre classique parce qu'il n'y a pas
de mariage rue marbeuf
je ne sais pas si les syriens sont
mariés avec les français mais la rue
marbeuf est une affaire un peu étrange
alors moi je pratique la recherche de la
vérité et j'aimerais bien connaître la
vérité je ne la connais pas plus que
vous c'est terrible
pourtant l'avocat qui ait connaissance
du dossier je ne venais pas plus que on
nous balade tout le monde est baladé et
quand je vois que ce cher nicolas
sarkozy finit par signer suzy s'adresser
à mon gros loup jeudi qu' on est dans un
monde assez étrange alors vous écrivez
je ne vois pas pourquoi on condamne
oussama ben laden alors que la majorité
des conseillers de george bush
appartiennent et des sectes
fondamentalistes dont la philosophie est
plus proche du fascisme que de la
tolérance
vous avez le sens du paradoxe quand même
non non c'est pas du paradoxe et c'est
une lucidité
non parce que j'ai l'impression que
l'intolérance elle est plutôt du côté
des dirigeants 20-15 je dis pas les
états unis ni les américains en général
ils dirigeants américains sont
intolérants plus par rapport à bergen
c'est indéfendable oussama ben laden où
je connais pas personnellement je ne
sais pas ce qu'il a fait et je vais pas
le condamner par avance
c'est pas parce que les idées les
dirigeants américains l'ont désigné
comme le maître d'oeuvre de tous leurs
malheurs que on est objectif
ouais alors effectivement dans le livre
que vous avez là près de vous qu'ils
s'appellent l'islam révolutionnaire qui
a été publié en 2003 au rocher vous
affirmer qu'en fait il ya aucune preuve
de l'implication de ben laden d'al-qaïda
dans les attentats du world trade center
mais ils ont revendiqué quand même un
moment non les revendications
c'est une preuve c'est que vous pensez
par exemple c'est très précis vous
pensez par exemple que la voix de ben
laden la cassette de ben laden
revendiquant l'attentât du world trade
center pour être un faux je ne suis ni
policier ni à la cia ni j'ai pas les
moyens de savoir et en général je ne
crois pas ce qui officialise et des
scores en général c'est qu'il ya un
intérêt officialisé une information pour
en tirer un profit
ça fait partie du les manoeuvres sur
l'opinion publique isabelle c'est
sûrement une mauvaise chose que de
croire systématiquement ce que dit
l'information officielle mais de dire
systématiquement le contraire c'est
aussi grave
vous vous vous croyez en rien qu'on
croyait qu'il croyait en rien si on vous
dit je ne suis pas sûr que ben laden est
comme une white night center j'ai vu que
oussama ben laden est un outil des états
unis au départ après contre le
communisme débat la ccc le c'est le fils
qui n'est pas reconnaissant quand il
faudrait il se retourne contre son
maître
bon à part ça quels sont les quelle est
la stratégie des états unis mme j'ai
l'impression que c'est comme mais
malheureusement pour eux non plus un
interlocuteur organisé c'est l avantage
de la guerre froide
ils sont obligés de de jouer un peu au
hasard et puis comme tout en pierre en
fait il faut s'invente un adversaire non
seulement mais en plus tout empire a
tendance à vouloir perdurer et donc le
seul moyen c'est de contrôler le monde
entier est ce que dit jean christophe
rufin en globalia c'était un moment
tellement deux amis d'ailleurs on était
obligé ça vaut rien inventé un
adversaire alors vous venez de loin
comme isabelle la part de loin pas de
loin vous êtes une origine
bourgeoise vos grands parents paternels
habitait rue de bretagne dans l'immeuble
de la famille giscard d'estaing votre
père était directeur de la garantie
mutuelle des fonctionnaires c'est pas
écrire un livre une certaine où je peux
savoir des choses qui sont pas écrites
dans l'armée oui si vous voulez oui
scolarité au cou ratner où il ya eu
bernadette chirac
ensuite le couvent des oiseaux ensuite
sainte-marie de neuilly marié trois
enfants donc au départ on peut pas dire
vous étiez prédisposé à tenir ce genre
de propos est encore plus a épousé le
fameux carlos quand même non écoutez
j'ai toute mon enfance j'ai entendu des
critiques sur les gouvernements
successifs y compris contre le général
de gaulle à votre père était mendésiste
oui mais des critiques contre l'ordre
établi on va dire ah oui malgré tout les
cas ils veulent maintenant ah oui malgré
tout d'abord associés explique cela
alors vos premiers contacts avec carlos
c'est le 27 juin 1997
et alors là carlos vous fait un
baise-main dans le couloir d'entrée de
la prison de la santé et là vous dites
il ya une espèce dont de reconnaissance
une alchimie étrange c'est vrai que
c'est assez surréaliste quand on arrive
dans une prison de l'avocat arrive dans
la prison avec tout son haut rang
puisque les prisonniers sur les pauvres
chose j'aime bien le dire est que on
trouve en face de soi quelqu'un qui
adore de garde prétorienne parce qu'il
était entouré de gendarmes en armes en
tenue de deux ninjas j'aime presque 100
et puis que tout benoîtement il me fait
un baise-main comme si on était ailleurs
quelque sorte
donc ça c'est surprenant ça attire
l'attention et ensuite il ya quelque
chose qui se crée entre des êtres
humains ce point très bien pourquoi
l'alchimie étrangement et puis quand ça
dure
et quand on s'entend tellement bien et
qu'on est il ya une telle complicité
intellectuelle
dans ce cas-là s'avère que c'est des
gens qui sont faits l'un pour l'autre
alors justement à l'époque j'étais
responsable donc du collectif d'avocats
chargés de défendre carlos mais quelques
mois plus tard vous décidez de quitter
la défense
que vous trouvez tout ça finalement
c'est pas sérieux c'est une parodie de
justice dit vous et carlos vous d'y
rester avec moi j'ai besoin de vous
défendez moi pourquoi vous n'y a pas eu
de casting non plus hein c'est pas vrai
si avec 40 avocats auxquels sur les
starting blocks
donc il ajouté tout ça vous le plus
besoin cette bête
bah oui les autres c'était des tons tout
en robe en plus à nous il faut croire
mais alors là vous dites impact est
serré entre nous et bientôt on insiste
la naissance de ce que vous appelez
entre guillemets un tendre sentiment
on sait très progressif effectivement
c'est pas un essai très profond ouais or
le 25 août 2001
carlos demande votre main dans un cagibi
qui fait deux mètres sur deux la prison
de la santé
comme il était initialement faut savoir
que ces vitres et ces endroits donc à un
témoin qui est à l'extérieur au moment
où ils vous demandent votre main
isabelle vous savez que quoi qu'il
puisse arriver dans l'avenir
vous savez bien que ça après tout de
suite parce que quand on est condamné à
perpétuité en france a vraiment dire
perpétuité quand je ne sais pas si c'est
un cas vraiment pas ouais alors donc
vous êtes désormais mari et femme sous
la loi de la charia puisque lui s'est
converti à l'islam et vous non non mais
c'est pas une obligation pour un mariage
vous êtes mariés selon le rite coranique
c'est ça voilà ce qui veut dire qu'il a
le droit d'avoir d'autres femmes
oui mais j'avais toujours dit d'accord
quand les femmes ont les mêmes droits
que les hommes musulmans et c'est ce que
j'ai fait parce qu'en réalité on s'est
mariés j'étais pas encore divorcé et
donc les conditions et 48 mes conditions
alors ce qu'il faudrait aussi au passage
c'est carlos s'est converti à l'islam au
départ parce que ça sent bizarre ce type
qui était marxiste léniniste et d'un
seul coup il se convertit à l'islam et
vous expliquer plus tôt par camaraderie
que par conviction en fait j'étais dans
un camp du fplp de georges habache hall
yémen il commandait des musulmans et
c'était plus facile pour lui en fait
les conduire au paradis s'ils étaient
musulmans aussi c'est la raison première
annoncé lui qu'il explique dans ce livre
est justement il comment il peut faire
coexister dans sa philosophie le
marxisme et l'islam si l'air de trouver
ça c'est cohérent lui dise des choses
qui sont vraiment révolutionnaire c'est
sa foi au départ c'est pas franchement
fait pour s'entendre comme un
révolutionnaire
il a compris très tôt que bien avant ce
qu'on appelle l'écroulement du mur de
berlin que comme révolutionnaire il
fallait bien trouver des forces et il
les a trouvés dans le sang ouais ouais
d'accord donc aujourd'hui pour carlos
finalement les damnés de la terre c'est
plus les prolétaires c'est les musulmans
chez les islamistes
un jour non je crois pas que les guînes
non je vous jure il s'implique c'est à
dire que les damnés de la terre
simplement vous avez d'un côté ceux qui
donnent les coûts et les autres qui les
reçoivent
il ya un moment où ceux qui reçoivent
les coups dit ça suffit
et c'est vrai que ça peut chauffer assez
fort à la fin ça peut se comprendre
alors aujourd'hui carlos donc et dans
une centrale à 260 km de paris condamné
à perpétuité
quand même difficile dans ces cas-là
d'avoir une vie sexuelle équilibré oui
c'est sûr que c'est pas tellement
confortable est-ce qu'il ya pas de
parloir sexuelle écoutez ici en avait en
tout cas moi j'ai pas l'intention
d'aller dans des baisodrome organisé par
l'administration pénitentiaire
je sais que l'administration distribuer
des préservatifs
donc apparemment l'administration que la
promotion de l'homosexualité mais j'ai
pas mais laissant alors bon maintenant
vous posez
j'ai bien compris que de manière
délicate vous le demander mais alors
comment faites-vous freins ce qui pour
moi est rare de vie de manière délicate
je remercie je vous remercie le court
terme et est marié avec quelqu'un qui
est en prison à deux cent soixante
bornes à perpétuité oui c'est réputé
pour être quand même un petit passé
dragueur et c'est ça c'est pas de
questions a sûrement alors moi ce que je
peux dire c'est que j'ai un mari
absolument idéal qui met ce libre toutes
les nuits oui ça je peux vous dire c'est
vrai que là vous savez où il est lui est
ce que il vous envoie des lettres
oui hein parce qu'ils envoient des
lettres un journal le journal de marc
edouard nabe qui s'appelle la vérité est
il écrit un marc edouard nabe 1 et les
lettres sont publiés dans la vérité oui
magnifique
il a le droit de faire ça bah il a le
droit du correspondant l'administration
regarde ce qu'il écrit et quand marc
edouard nabe lui écrit l'administration
prendrait certainement plus ces
photocopies
elle transmet à qui de droit je sais me
pose donc c'est en tout bien tout
honneur et de manière tout à fait
ouverte et vous le voyez tous les comble
alors mais j'essaye d'aller chaque
semaine mais je peux aller plus qu'un
jour il ya la télé oui mais c'est pareil
que enfin ils fouillent doit payer à
l'horizon mais le soir je garde tout le
monde en parle oui j'espère que ce soir
il va me regarder
vous avez quelque chose à lui dire la
profitez-en face caméra la sologne
j'aimerais bien être avec lui mais je
suis ravi d'être avec terreur disent on
est alors pour vous en gros carlos n'est
pas un criminel mais un homme politique
qui sera un jour légalement libérer ces
ca du pôle est vraiment c'est à dire
qu'il a toujours dit qu il refuse toute
libération illégal ce qu'on appelle
libération élégance et une évasion en
fait ouais donc il a clairement dit
depuis longtemps il a eu des
propositions très claires pas par en
interne - ce que je me cherche pas de
choses hein mais je dirais même d'autres
confrères il a toujours refusé parce
qu'il considère que ça serait
inadmissible par rapport à son parcours
de vie
ce cachet d'être plans dessins c'est un
bon travail creuser les malins je
considère comme un prisonnier politique
oui c'est pas qu'ils considèrent ils les
droits de tout le démontre la lève mans
les huit ans d'isolement 1
normal alors autour de vous quelles ont
été les réactions par exemple vos
enfants que j'ai trois enfants à mes
enfants
pas de problème 1 c'est mes parents qui
se sentent responsables de moi qui ont
été un peu plus soucieux le bar où ça a
été dur aussi avec les avocats la tête
guen le bâtonnier qui vous a dit que
c'est la provocation vraiment service
commandé un jeu je suppose agité par le
parquet ou je ne sais pas quelle
autorité gouvernementale mais c'est vrai
que ça ne leur convenait pas du tout oui
ça ne dérangeait l'organisation des
choses là et vous en faites vous avez
dit a pas de loi qui m'interdit
d'épouser carlos non seulement il n'y a
pas de l'eau mais en plus ce qu'on
pourrait supputer c'est que je perde la
tête que dans un état de fusion totale
je ne puissent plus avoir le recul
nécessaire pour l'exercice correcte du
métier mais ça n'a rien changé puisque
j'avais assez d'entraînement enfin deux
points je vous croyez pas sérieusement
que c'est quelque chose comme ça on a
connu beaucoup de filles comme ça des
années 70 défis qui venait d'un milieu
très très bourgeois qui d'un seul coup
pour provoquer leur famille pour se
rebeller contre l'ordre établi il
faisait des choses absolument incroyable
comme d'épouser carlos pouquoi pas qu'il
y ait quelque chose comme ça au départ
dont elle manie parker un peu ben oui
mais pourquoi pas si vous avez envie de
penser ça commençait mal j'ai envie de
manger rien de penser je vous dis la
vérité j'essaye de comprendre je ne
crois pas être en phase de règlement de
compte familial freudien donc non ça
veut savoir s'il ya une fascination pour
les mauvais garçons qui réapprend les
mauvais pour les voyous les grands
voyous un danger par procuration
non parce que je vois que des
inconvénients pas assez sûr c'est pas
facile mais c'est pas du tout
confortable
non non tu en penses quoi toi de cette
histoire non je trouve ça très beau
c'est une belle histoire d'amour c'est
c'est merveilleux c'est incroyable non
mais on peut naître à la suite au
prochain épisode
il faut voir justement imaginer un
dénouement heureux dont il sort il est
libéré et puis brusquement quand vous
allez vraiment vous retrouver en tête à
tête dans un appartement totalement lui
je vais le passer un beauf isabelle
gautheron
seul coup sans épouser carnot
aux éditions de l'archipel quel étonnant
cette histoire vous restez avec nous je
crois que je suis aux assises en ce
moment oui vous avez défendu les bretons
là et c'est pas fini d'écrire alors ces
bretons ils ont raison d'après vous ils
ont des droits ils ont de bons qu'ils
ont des droits ils ont le droit de les
faire valoir
les nouvelles jacques vergès non faut
bien que c'est pas un homme de pardon
merci j'avais
oui
m